hey if you want to show your love for
the seventh at least since and support
this channel at the same time check out
our brand new online store we have
original designs like this esken or
praise the Sun shirt created by Pro
artist Cuusoo Marie
you can't find these designs anywhere
else so check us out at anime uproar
calm link in the description fans of the
channel can now use a special discount
code uproar 25 at checkout to receive an
instant 25 percent off
[Music]
what is up everybody its Anna Mack here
for anime uproar and because so many of
you wonderful ladies and gentlemen
requested it in this video I will be
talking about the seven deadly sins
prisoners of the sky which has finally
been released outside of Japan through
Netflix as a massive fan of the seven
deadly sins I definitely enjoyed
prisoners of the sky it gave us a chance
to see all seven sins Elizabeth and
Hawke interacting with each other in
their usual hilarious style and best of
all we also got to see Hawks mama in
action once again
spoiler alert Hawks mama is definitely
best girl in this one as usual if you
enjoy these types of videos you want to
see more you can leave a like to let me
know and if you're new to the channel
don't forget to subscribe and hit that
notification bell now aside from the
classic seven deadly sins comedy in
action including meliodas failing at
cooking once again and Eskin or puking
on everybody this new story also gave us
some major reveals about the world of
the seven deadly sins we met new demons
new goddesses and we learned some very
interesting things about the holy war
about merlin and of course about hawks
mama but the big question on all of our
minds right now is this is this story
part of the official seven deadly sins
timeline is it canon if it is then all
of these crazy reveals are all the more
interesting because they may play a
major role in the future of the main
story so what's the consensus is it
canon well actually there is an argument
to be made both ways on the non-canon
side there is the fact that this story
was not directly tied in with the main
story and the fact that the timeline
seems a bit off
for instance esken or is seen hanging
out with the rest of the sins as they
prepare to attend king Patras birthday
party and the ten commandments are
nowhere to be found but we know that
ESCA noir was introduced into the main
story after the ten commandments were
already released from the coffin of
eternal darkness so why would the sins
just be casually hanging out and having
birthday parties when the ten
commandments are out there causing havoc
and consuming innocent souls but on the
bright side this new story is closely
linked to the seven deadly sins manga in
fact it was deliberately foreshadowed in
the official manga in Chapter 203 of the
seven deadly sins manga the six nights
of black the main antagonists of the new
story were actually mentioned and their
strength was directly compared to the
strength of the Ten Commandments the
Endura of retribution that appears near
the end of prisoners of the sky was also
introduced in the manga the name of the
sin Dora is burro ha and he was said to
be an acquaintance of Galan finally
these new characters were created by the
mangaka naba Kazuki himself not by some
third party or studio in the past anime
characters that appeared only in movies
and were not connected to the main
storyline did become canon later so it
is definitely possible that the events
of prisoners of the sky will have some
sort of impact on the main storyline
after all if this news story was meant
to be completely separate from the main
story why go through all the trouble of
introducing characters from prisoners of
the sky into the official manga
including of course the six nights of
black and the Endura of retribution I
mean I'm already seeing a bunch of
people commenting that of course this is
completely separate everyone who thinks
that this will link back to the main
storyline is an idiot and so on and if
that's what you think then that is fine
with me
but we have to remember that they could
have just kept this completely separate
the fact that they chose to introduce
the characters in the manga is
meaningful to me now let's get into the
specifics of the movie at the very
beginning of prisoners of the sky we are
introduced to the Celestials creatures
who are descendants of the goddesses and
live in the sky temple which is a
majestic village that floats high in the
sky as we learn from so loud a celestial
who came down to earth to find a way to
stop the coming attack by powerful
demons the Celestials falsely believed
that the demons won the previous holy
war and that they wiped out all the
other races on earth for some reason
they believed that the demons ruled the
earth and everyone else has been
eliminated which is actually pretty
noteworthy when you think about it this
means that there are entire
civilizations out there who are
completely the
attached from what's going on in
Britannia so who knows what we may learn
about the world of the seven deadly sins
as the story continues one thing that
really stood out to me and was clearly
done on purpose was the fact that Sola
and his fiancee a lot a look a lot like
Mellie Otis and Elizabeth they look so
similar that even people who are closest
to them cannot tell them apart
at first glance which again really makes
you think why do these two couples look
so much like each other we know that
Elizabeth in her original body was like
goddess so she is the ancestor of the
Celestials but is there some other more
direct connection between her meliodas
and salade in a latte
the movie never actually explains this
but it's definitely one of those things
that makes you wonder will this be
explained sometime in the future I am
very curious about it and I want to know
what you guys think so let me know down
in the comments is there some family
connection between Elizabeth and a latte
is it just a huge coincidence or is
something else going on another very
interesting moment occurs when sole odd
asks all the sins - Millie Otis who is
not present at the time if they are
members of the demon clan Merlin states
that none of them are members of the
demon clan this is important because
Merlin's true race has been the subject
of intense debate for a very long time
and some believe that she is secretly a
demon or at least part demon however he
or she says that Eska Norris human bond
is a former human and she is and I quote
well something like that so she tells us
that she is definitely not a demon and
that she is something like a human but
still leaves her exact trace a mystery
Merlin's true race is honestly one of
the most interesting unsolved mysteries
in the seven deadly sins for me
personally and I think I may have to
make a video on it soon because I do
have my own theory about Merlin's true
race eventually we meet the six nights
of black who are the primary antagonists
of the story as the legend goes three
thousand years ago during the previous
holy war the six nights of black and
other demons were fighting against other
races in the sky temple
just as it looked as if the demons were
about to win and destroy everyone in the
temple a mythical shining white pig-like
creature appeared and helped the goddess
clan seal the demons within the egg Rock
a giant stone structure this white
pig-like creature was called the great
Oshiro and is still revered by the
Celestials three thousand years later
the seal of the egg rock breaks and the
demons attack again including of course
the six nights of black it is implied
that before they were sealed away the
six nights of black were so violent that
even the Ten Commandments struggled with
them and Bell Ian the leader of the six
nights of black claims that his skills
have surpassed the Ten Commandments at
one point belly and wanted to become one
of the Ten Commandments but meliodas
didn't allow him to join and he still
holds a grudge against meliodas because
of this however despite the comparisons
to the Ten Commandments it is pretty
clear that none of the six nights of
black can measure up to someone like zel
dress or esta rosa and even bell Ian who
is the strongest would only be at the
level of Derry Ehrmann speed in my
personal opinion anyway this is what
happens to the six nights of black the
haka gets absolutely wrecked by
melioidosis full counter atre also known
as a Tola gets tag-teamed by King and
gold sir bond basically hogs pumped to
death and discount esken or also known
as the Rocio gets absolutely pimp
slapped by Merlin and the real esken or
finally Gaara the female demon is taken
out by Deanne and King the only one of
the six nights of black that poses a
more significant threat is the leader
belly in but even he gets taken out by
Mele ODIs one smelly ODIs actually
begins to use his full power but before
he dies belly and sacrifices his own
soul and the souls of the other knights
of black in order to resurrect the
Endura of retribution a massive and
extremely powerful demonic beast at this
point we get to see some excellent
teamwork at play as everyone comes
together to defeat the Endura Hawks mama
swallows a blast from the Endura
and sends it back at the monster in
order to weaken it so lad creates a
massive arc with the help of the other
Celestials and Elizabeth and the Ark
seals the Endura in place
finally meliodas uses an epic combo
moved in
wolves all of the sins the other sins
launched their full power attacks at
malleolus he uses his clones to direct
all of the attacks at himself and then
he full counters the massive attack into
the Endura destroying it in epic fashion
the attack is called the seven deadly
sins and I have to say I really loved at
this moment I loved seeing all the sins
working together and then calling the
move the seven deadly sins did kind of
give me goose bumps not gonna lie but
moving on there are two more details
that seem very important and may end up
being relevant in the main story
sometime in the future the first is the
winged sword which we learn was created
specifically to fight against the demon
clan it has the power to seriously wound
even high-ranking demons like meliodas
and stop them from regenerating while
the sword is still inside their body and
it also has the power to seal away high
ranked demons one thing that I found
fascinating is that not even Eskin or in
his day form could wield the sword only
the head warrior of the Celestials could
which means that this sword has some
extremely powerful magic attached to it
I am really curious about this sword and
since in the main story we've already
had several swords that have had hidden
powers including of course dragon handle
and Excalibur I wonder whether the
winged sword will make an appearance in
the main storyline as well finally we
have of course the great oshiro the
great oshiro is a giant shining white
pig-like creature that was believed to
have saved the sky temple from the
demons 3,000 years ago and at this point
we're all thinking well Hawks mama is a
giant pig-like creature with mysterious
magical abilities including of course
the ability to swallow powerful attacks
however Hawks mama is green so she can't
be the great oshiro right not right
because at the very end of the movie we
see a small part of Hawks Mama's green
skin or shell peeled to reveal a shining
white surface below clearly implying
that Hawks mama is indeed the great
Oshiro the winged sword is believed to
have somehow been created by the great
Oshiro and according to Merlin the great
for Shiro is just another name for the
mother of Kay
the mother of chaos is the creature who
gave birth to all the monsters of the
world presumably including all creatures
who are not part of the five main races
and clans including the vampires and the
beast men the mother of chaos is said to
have contained so much darkness that she
was feared by the demon clan while at
the same time possessing so much light
that she was revered by the goddess clan
now there will be some manga spoilers
from this point on regarding hawks so if
you haven't read the manga proceed with
caution
we know that Hawk is actually a creature
that was born in purgatory and that he
has a brother called wild who remained
in purgatory and who held malleolus and
bond fight against the demon king Hawk
appears to have been kidnapped by the
demon king and sent into the world of
the seven deadly sins as a way for the
demon king to spy on Mellie Otis through
Hawks eyes at this point we don't know
if Hawks mama is actually Hawks birth
mother there is no conclusive evidence
as a right now but if Hawks mama is the
mother of chaos then it is possible that
she is the mother of all creatures from
purgatory including hawk and wild one
piece of evidence that may support this
is the fact that in Arthurian legend
there is a pig called hanwen or old
white saw a white pig just like the
great oshiro and in Arthurian legend
this pig gave birth to a monstrous cat
creature called calf [ __ ] and other
mysterious creatures
we know that Arthur's mysterious
cat-like pet is also named calf and we
know that calf is a creature from
purgatory and since we know how greatly
inspired the seven deadly sins story is
by Arthurian legend
it isn't far-fetched to assume that if
calf is a creature from purgatory and
hawks mama is the mother of chaos who
gave birth to all monsters then just
like in Arthurian legend this great
white pig could be the mother of calf
and of other creatures from purgatory
including hawk and wild Hawks mama
secretly being such a strong legendary
creature would explain why Merlin's
tattoo looks so much like hawk it may
actually be inspired by Hawks mama and
her legendary power and of course this
revelation if it turns out to be canon
could have major implications on the
main storyline in the near future I mean
the mother of chaos one of the strongest
legendary creatures has been right here
this whole time
under our very noses it's pretty crazy
and in fact I'm considering making a
full video on hawk at Hawks mama let me
know if that's something you guys would
want to see so overall in terms of
prisoners of the sky I really enjoyed it
it was a bit rushed at times as most
movies are because they don't have
nearly as much time as a full anime
season so because of that the six nights
of black seemed pretty underwhelming and
they were taken out by the seven deadly
sins fairly easily but nevertheless I
really enjoyed seeing all of the sins
working together and hanging out along
with of course Hawk Elizabeth and Hawks
mama and if this story does turn out to
be canon in any way then we just got
some major information about the world
of the seven deadly sins and its
characters the fact that the Celestials
direct descendents of the goddess clan
are still around in their own physical
body is a major revelation the fact that
Hawks mama is the mother of chaos is a
huge revelation and the stuff about the
winged sword and Merlin definitely not
being a demon but rather something like
a human is extremely interesting as well
as always with the story of the seven
deadly sins I can't wait to find out
more and please stay tuned to this
channel because I will be covering all
of the important seven deadly sins
updates and revelations in the future
feel free to let me know what you
thought about the movie and about what's
going to happen next in the story by
following at anime uproar on Twitter and
Instagram and hitting me up if you
enjoyed this video you want to see more
something that Lee sense videos you can
leave a like to let me know if you're
new to the channel don't forget to
subscribe and hit that notification bell
and if you want to support more content
on this channel and get awesome merch at
the same time check out our online store
link in the description as always thank
you guys so much for watching thank you
for all the requests for me to make this
video and until next time see us space
cowboys
[Music]
you